[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau cette ut le journal voici les
titres
un homme est activement recherché par
les autorités armé d'une kalachnikov ils
auraient fait feu dans la nuit de lundi
à mardi
plus d'informations dans ce journal la
première édition du jumping
international a eu lieu le week end
dernier à versailles
les meilleurs cavaliers du monde se sont
affrontés dans la résidence du roi
soleil
un événement qui a fait le bonheur des
spectateurs notre portrait de la semaine
est dédiée un passionné de théâtre
christophe leray baigne dans cet univers
depuis 17 ans il est aujourd'hui
président de la troupe du crâne troupe
de théâtre qui l'a accueilli à l'âge de
13 ans on ouvre ce journal avec cette
information un homme armé d'une
kalachnikov est activement recherché par
la police il aurait tiré sur un homme de
23 ans à trappes dans la nuit de lundi à
mardi selon plusieurs témoins l'auteur
des faits est le meurtrier du burger
king de plaisir également auteur d'une
tentative de meurtre à trappes dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi
on referme cette page et direction bois
d'arcy
vendredi dernier la commune a signé une
convention ad qu'orange pour
l'installation de la fibre optique
c'était l'une des promesses du maire
philippe benassaya écouter l'eau on a un
gros projet un énorme projet numérique
sur la ville et ce projet numérique
était un petit peu ralenti du fait qu'on
n'avait pas la fibre à bois d'arcy
le projet c'est le numérique à l'école
la dématérialisation des services le
télétravail pour les arcisien et puis
notre zone d'activités de la croix
bonnet qui est déjà fibré mais dont les
habitants n'avaient pas encore bénéficié
de la de la fibre
donc on avait un vrai challenge à
relever c'est est d'accélérer un petit
peu ce qu'on appelait à l'époque des
autoroutes de l'information et c'est
vrai que pour l'instant on avait pris
une nationale belle nationale mais
n'était pas encore sur l'autoroute il
baigne dans l'univers du théâtre depuis
17 ans en tant que comédien amateur ou
encore scénographe
cet homme c'est christophe leray
aujourd'hui président de la troupe du
crâne troupe de théâtre qui l'a
accueilli à l'âge de 13 ans christophe
leray ans passionné c'est un portraits
croqués par mélanie poker toutes ces
scènes aussi dans le château ou relooker
petit à petit d'ailleurs j'ai plein de
projets à voir avec nous on veut en
profiter
il n'y travaille plus depuis deux ans
mais christophe leray n'a pas rompu ses
liens avec le château de breteuil dans
ses scénographies il avait énormément
d'imagination de bord il savait
construire une scène à partir de rien
ici oui niveau c'était un endroit
complètement perdu une ancienne céleri
en ruine et serra il est arrivé à en
faire quelque chose de
de merveilleux l'un des travaux les plus
marquants de christophe la mise en scène
des contes de perrault
celui ci représente près de cinq mois de
travail
et puis ont gelé public dans l'histoire
de cendrillon c'est une vraie création
et dans un ancien local technique et et
tout a été créé de a à z dans cet espace
ici il y avait des tracteurs avant il y
à 7 ans christophe débute un stage au
château
il est chargé du développement culturel
c'est là que j'ai compris en fait que
c'était véritablement la muséographie
plus qu'un goût c'était une véritable
vocation de mener des projets de diriger
des équipes d'aboutir un résultat
d'avoir un d'établir un concept et puis
de le concrétiser un travail appris en
autodidacte mais cette passion lui vient
du théâtre un art qu'il pratique avec
une troupe saint-quentinoise
elle a commencée il ya 17 ans à l'âge de
13 ans je cherchais à avoir une activité
artistique beaucoup moins solitaire
puisque je faisais de la peinture depuis
l'âge de 6 ans mais c'est un travail
d'atelier j'ai intégré un conservatoire
à coignières dirigée par monique fonds
didion et au bout de trois mois il m'a
proposé un rôle dans sa troupe d'adultes
la troupe du crâne que j'ai intégré et
ce qui faisait que cette première année
à l'âge de mes 13 ans je faisais 8
heures de théâtre par semaine et ça
c'est un être particulièrement adorable
gentils tous vos étés à tout amour toute
intégrité et j'avoue que j'apprécie ça
ces démarches envers moi et sa
promptitude et les apparemment très
équilibré
c'est un homme de main également qu'il
sait faire les décors qui qu'il bricole
beaucoup qu'il a le sens de la scène et
le respect dû mettre 17 ans plus tard
christophe joue toujours avec la troupe
du crâne
il en est même devenu le président et
travaille à multiplier leurs
partenariats leur nouvelle résidence le
théâtre du château de brousse est
inaugurée en 1957 par la comédie
française à guyancourt la ville vient de
lancer des festivités pour les dix ans
de la batterie la salle prévoit jusqu'à
la fin de mai une série de concerts avec
une programmation éclectique daz
classique reggae ou encore pop au tarif
spécial de 10 euros la place
écoutez elle est unique parce que
justement elle est transversal les
transversales avec l'éducation donc
l'école de musique elle est transversal
avec les studios avec des professionnels
avec des professionnels en devenir
voilà cette dimension est quand même dès
le départ importante pour nous a dit en
cour d'avoir vraiment un public varié
après un public ou s'ils ont deux
directions de l'éducation mais aussi en
direction du territoire
on passe aux sports et des chevaux
étaient à l'honneur ce week end à
versailles
les meilleurs cavaliers du monde se sont
affrontés dans la résidence du roi
soleil pour la première édition du
jumping international
regardez un cadre prestigieux des
cavaliers de haut niveau 200 chevaux et
un public de connaisseurs bienvenue au
jumping international cinq étoiles de
versailles pour la première fois la
compétition était organisée du 5 au 7
mai dans les grandes écuries du château
hilali l'organisation d'une grande
compétition internationale au patrimoine
en étant au sein des écuries du château
de versailles
c'est une réussite exceptionnelle de
pouvoir avoir organisé ce concours et
ensuite la france inscrit dans sa
tournée de concours internationaux parmi
les plus grandes nations habitante et le
belle image au monde entend au casting
de cette première édition des champions
olympiques tricolores comme kevin staut
originaire du chéné star du cinéma
français guillaume canet mais également
l'une des légendes de ce sport le
brésilien de 44 ans rodrigo pessoa
médaillé d'or aux jo de 2004 et
vainqueur de 50 grands prix
internationaux tout au long de sa
carrière
l'équipe d'organisation sont des amis
depuis ya depuis longtemps relaxé un de
mes partenaires aussi depuis 19 ans donc
ils m'ont demandé d'être ambassadeur du
du concours de l'événement j'ai bien
évidemment accepté donc il fait je
devais être ici de très bons très bons
cavaliers c'est la conviction très
relevé sur les prochains jours
l'organisation de ce jumping permet
également de promouvoir la candidature
de paris aux jeux olympiques de 2024
si le dossier retenu les épreuves
équestres pourrait s'y dérouler c'est
pas une répétition parce que ça
ressemble en rien de ce que sera
l'illustrent les jeux olympiques mais en
tout cas c'est d'amener tous les acteurs
qui ont une action à tous les lieux
différents niveaux de rencontrer déjà le
site les actes auront l'occasion de
découvrir encore un peu plus le site sur
les prochaines éditions
le partenariat entre le château de
versailles et les organisateurs du
jumping international est signé jusqu'en
2019 et les yvelines où aussi rayonner
en boxe a dit lahm ou mady est redevenu
champion d'europe des poids super moyens
à 36 ans 13 mois après avoir perdu cette
ceinture le boxeur élan pour toi s'est
imposé sur les terres de l'espagnol
mariano hilario en le battant aux points
prochain objectif pour le boxeur
conquérir un titre mondial dans sa
catégorie et le succès était aussi au
rendez vous pour le club de rugby de
plaisir des joueurs plaisir oies se sont
imposés 31 à 16 à domicile contre marcq
en baroeul en 16e de finale en fédérale
3 cette victoire leur permet de prendre
une sérieuse option sur la qualification
en huitièmes de finale et la montée en
fédérale 2 michael et demi d'euros
le rugby-club de plaisir n'est plus qu'à
une marche de la montée en fédérale 2 ce
dimanche 7 mais les bleu et jaune ont
réussi leur meilleure prestation de la
saison contre marcq en baroeul pourtant
favori de la rencontre
après une première période convaincante
ponctuée par un 19 à 16 les plaisirs ont
accéléré pour marquer deux essais en
seconde période
ce camp final 31 tél aujourd'hui on
était présent au combat quoi devant on
était bien et on sait très bien trouver
derrière les gars ont fait des super
mouvement ça d'ailleurs été au bout
quasiment à chaque fois donc donc du
coup globalement le collectif ont été
très bons aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit
était top donc je pense que c'est ce que
puisqu'elle fonctionne c'est vraiment
l'âme dit je crois que c'est l'amie qui
a pris mais aujourd'hui avec encore une
fois une bonne application des
lancements de jeu
mais j'insiste lourdement mais c'est
vrai que c'était une énorme envie avec
des gars au grand donner le meilleur
d'eux mêmes après cette performance
stratosphérique les plaisirs en europe a
le temps de se reposer
le match retour est programmé dès ce
dimanche 14 mai sur le terrain de marcq
en baroeul
le staff s'attend à une opposition plus
coriace il vaut mieux quand même
recevoir sur un match retour forcément
mais eux auront la pression parce qu'ils
ont 15 points à remonter et que c'est à
eux à faire le jeu du match
cae a montré quelque chose à sortir un
grand match mais comme nous on n'a pas
du tout l'intention d'y aller
un seul et ça me fais rien et regarde
jouer donc je pense qu'on leur donnera
du fil à retordre pour ce match plaisir
devrait pouvoir compter sur un effectif
au complet une bonne nouvelle dans
l'optique de réaliser l'objectif du club
fixé en début de saison la montée en
fédérale 2 2 ans après l'avoir quittée
thé dansant une première à plaisir était
organisée à la salle des fêtes des
gâtines de des gâtines la vague de la
valse du tango et autres danse musette
était à l'honneur lors de cet événement
qui a réuni 120 danseurs
ah oui j'adore la danse
oui et voilà on retrouve des amis et
c'est vraiment une première qui est très
très sympathique pour nous voilà c'était
le rendez vous attendu par tous les
amateurs de danse rétro
le thé dansant organisé le 4 mai par la
mairie de plaisir dans la salle des
fêtes des gâtines une salle entièrement
rénovée un vrai orchestre beaucoup de
monde présent des danseurs des danseuses
qui n'hésitent pas à venir d'autres
communes pour leur passion danse rétro
[Musique]
le bouche à oreille me fait venir
cha cha cha tango valse mombo les danses
s'enchaînent près de 120 personnes sont
présentes des passionnés de danse mais
aussi des nouveaux danseurs pour
d'autres simplement une sortie une
occasion de se retrouver entre amis l'
orchestre enchaîne les succès d'antan on
se lance on s'amuse on répète avec
sérieux les pas de danse appris en cours
un succès pour cette première édition
que la mairie souhaite bien évidemment
renouvelé la prochaine édition aura lieu
le 1er juin nous nous retrouverons une
fois par mois après la pause estivale
donc nous reprendrons cette fréquence à
l'automne changements de rythmes
changement de partenaire parfois les
plus motivés ont ainsi pu danser pendant
près de deux heures
cette nouvelle activité à plaisir semble
enchanté tous les participants qui
reviendront le mois prochain avec
plaisir
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]